Trascrizione: Ilaria Camboni
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Quante volte da piccoli vi siete sentiti
dire: “No, questo non si fa”?
E quando chiedevi perché,
ti veniva detto: “Perché non si fa”.
Oppure: “Perché è sbagliato”,
senza che ti venisse data
una spiegazione approfondita.
Da bambino abitavo
con i miei nonni a Poggibonsi.
Avevo più o meno quattro anni e sentivo
particolarmente la mancanza di mia mamma.
Così un giorno decisi di andare a casa sua
che era dall’altra parte della città.
M’incamminai.
Arrivai davanti al portone,
lo trovai aperto.
Entrai, ma mamma non era in casa.
Quindi mi misi a sedere sulle scale
e aspettai che rientrasse.
Ma invece di mamma arrivò nonno
che mi riportò a casa.
E al mio ritorno c'era tutto il condominio
che mi stava aspettando.
Una signora, Fosca si chiamava,
mi disse una frase
che mi si stampò in testa:
“Non lo fare mai più
perché ti portano via gli zingari”.
Allora non capivo, quello che diceva
per me non aveva senso.
Oggi capisco.
Quanti timori e pregiudizi ci sono ancora
nei confronti del diverso,
di ciò che non conosciamo.
C’è sempre stato questo timore
nei confronti di persone appartenenti
a una cultura diversa dalla nostra,
o che avevano un aspetto insolito,
o un comportamento sociale non adeguato.
Per come sono cresciuto, mi sento di dire
che sono dalla parte dei freak,
di quegli elementi della società
che non si inquadrano
in un contesto ben preciso,
e che per questo motivo
vengono emarginati,
a volte presi come bersaglio di critiche,
nei casi peggiori, come soggetti
sui quali sfogare la propria rabbia.
Quegli elementi della società che De André
ha ampiamente descritto nei suoi brani.
E per questo amo il lavoro
di Diane Arbus.
Diane Arbus è una fotografa americana,
vissuta tra gli anni ’20
e gli anni ’70 del Novecento,
che ha dedicato
la sua fotografia ai freak, appunto,
a questi soggetti
ai margini della società,
interrogandosi su cosa fosse la normalità,
chi e cosa è normale.
Per lo stesso motivo,
ho deciso di fotografare mia madre.
Che cosa è normale?
Che cosa è vero?
Che cosa è bello?
Prima la bellezza era questa.
Una bellezza molto diversa
da quella a cui siamo abituati oggi.
Fin da piccoli cresciamo
con una serie di norme,
di canoni e di convenzioni
che ci si attaccano addosso
fino a diventare la nostra seconda pelle,
parte della nostra identità.
Che siano i canoni di bellezza,
il sistema d’informazione,
le abitudini alimentari,
l’impianto religioso
o l’impianto economico.
Cresciamo in un contesto
in cui tutto ciò che rientra
all’interno di questi parametri
risulta normale.
Ciò che si discosta,
strano o diverso.
E questo è anche il motivo
del nascere di pregiudizi e di stereotipi.
Perché se vediamo un arabo
con una valigetta in mano
su un mezzo di trasporto pubblico
pensiamo che sia un terrorista?
Perché ci facciamo ancora problemi
se una persona ha il colore della pelle
diverso dal nostro?
O se una persona è attratta
da una persona dello stesso sesso.
Ora, questi discorsi e questi concetti
sono sentiti e risentiti.
Se ne parla di continuo
e sembra che ognuno di noi li condivida.
Sembra che ognuno di noi sia d’accordo
sul fatto che non sia giusto
discriminare altre persone.
Però perché allora ci sono ancora
divisioni e disuguaglianze?
E violenze dovute a queste disuguaglianze?
Questo si chiama perbenismo.
A me il perbenismo non piace.
Che cosa facciamo nel concreto
ogni giorno per cambiare le cose?
Rispettiamo davvero
profondamente il prossimo?
Abbiamo davvero una mente aperta
e pronta ad accogliere?
Io penso che sia dovere di ognuno di noi,
non solo di chi fa un mestiere creativo,
o di chi ricopre ruoli importanti,
penso sia dovere di ognuno di noi
mettere e mettersi in discussione,
farsi domande,
imparare a guardare le cose
da più punti di vista.
Cercare di conoscere
ciò che non conosciamo,
perché è su questi principi che si basa
la comprensione e l’accoglienza.
E poi alla fine, per cambiare
le cose non c’è da fare chissà che.
Basta una cosa.
Il rispetto.
Il rispetto in tutte le sue forme.
Grazie.